la reine quitte buckingham pour une
dernière fois
dans le centre de londres une procession
des plus solennelles
derrière la dépouille le nouveau
monarque et les autres membres de la
famille royale pour un instant les
différents semble laisser de côté
destination le palais de westminster
si la queue comme son père sa mère et
winston churchill avant elle elizabeth 2
sera exposée en chapelle ardente pour
les quatre prochains jours
[Musique]
le long du parcours une foule imposante
au point que certains spectateurs ont dû
être refoulée
c'est donc sur leur écran téléphone que
se sont rabattus ces londoniens de toute
façon ils ont des heures devant eux en
attendant pouvoir se recueillir devant
le cercueil royal et 16 mois après cela
ce sera un moment intime anticipent
cette canadienne établie à londres
depuis plusieurs années une fois son
recueillement terminée elle agira comme
bénévole
je vis ici c'est mon devoir dit elle car
dans la capitale les besoins
organisationnels sont immenses
circulation rappelle d instruction est
suivi de santé auprès dessus que la
longue attente pourrait affecter après
trente trois mille personnes qui ont
défilé devant la dépouille à edimbourg
les autorités londoniennes s'attendent à
un afflux encore plus important pour
être pratiquement au devant de la file
cet homme a dormi sur les rives de la
tamise mais pour lui attendre importe
peu amon tanoh l'enjeu because she is
not enough to leave the office il
explique que la reine continuer
d'occuper son rôle alors qu'à 72 81 ans
il aurait dû être à la retraite
selon lui c'est lui la distance qui a su
conserver la reine avec la politique
pour être l'un des premiers à le
remercier il aura attendu une journée
unique il est presque 17 heures heure
locale moment auquel les britanniques
pourront commencer à se recueillir
devant la dépouille de la reine on
retrouve ici environ quatre kilomètres
de westminster le lieu se tient cette
chapelle ardente et 7 longues files
d'attenté continuent de s'allonger
cette ampleur n'avait été vu dans ce
pays constate selon denis pourtant
habitué des événements royaux
une fois 17 heures arrivée la foule
entreprend son mouvement le rythme est
encourageant mais vu la distance à
parcourir il faudra encore patienter
avant passer quelques secondes seulement
pour tourner une page d'histoire 0
revoir à celle qui a régné sur le pays
pendant cette décennie six rafale bouvy
auclair radio canada à londres